on va revenir maintenant sur la
fernaelle justement puisque ça y est
elle a eu une issue on va revenir sur
l'info principale de cette journée à
20h59 en direct la remise en liberté du
policier hauteur du tir mortel sur le
jeune naë en juin dernier policier 38
ans mis en examen pour homicide
volontaire dormu en prison depuis le 29
juin dernier il est désormais placé sous
contrôle judiciaire on va revenir sur
tout ça et jean-méa vous avez créé une
cagnotte pour le policier vous allez
nous en parler dans un instant puisque
vous avez été vous allez être entendu
par la police d'ailleurs à cause de
cette canot vous allez nous en parler
dans un instant Reda vous reste avec
nous euh puisque vous allez nous dire ce
qui s'est passé on va revoir ces images
de ce qui s'est passé à Nanterre le 27
juin dernier
regardez il est rentré oh
alors Reda Béage lorsque vous
avez appris l'annonce de la remise en
liberté de ce policier vous avez réagi
comment pour vous c'était une victoire
ah non pas une victoire on a été soulagé
on a été soulagé parce que pour nous un
policier n'a pas ça sa place dans le cas
d'une action je dis bien dans dans le
cadre d'une action de police n'a pas sa
place en détention provisoire tout
simplement le collègue il s'est pas levé
le matin en disant tiens je vais aller
tirer sur un jeune c'est pas du tout le
cas parce que j'ai fu d'autres plateaux
j'entends un peu tout et rien et faut
savoir que ce collègue quand vous faites
un jugement la première chose qu'on fait
c'est établir le profil du mise en cause
aujourd'hui le collègue qui est mise en
cause il a 10 il a 10 ans
d'administration ou il a une médaille de
sécurité intérieure ce qui est très rare
dans les services de police il a de deux
médailles de d'acte courage et
dévouement maintenant il a voulu faire
son travail la justice dira si il il
était dans le cadre légal et
réglementaire ou pas mais en tout cas il
a essayé de faire son travail et
normalement l'État devrait prendre en
compte cette chose là et ce collègue là
de manière rigoureuse en est mettant en
place une protection fonctionnelle on a
eu aussi d'autres problèmes on a vu
qu'il y a eu les émeutes et tout on a eu
beaucoup de policiers qui ont été visés
parce queon arrive il faudrait tout
simplement nous TGP on demande à ce que
tout ce tous les les noms des collègues
soient anonymisés au niveau de des
procédures tout simplement alors Gill
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au procès
pourquoi il était remis en liberté alors
non les les juges d'instruction l'ont
entendu et en fait il avait déjà fait
des demandes de remise en liberté qui
ont été rejeté parce que les juges avait
peur qu'il se concerte avec l'autre
policier l'autre motard qui était là ce
jour-là comme leur version du point de
vue du procureur peuvent diverger le
juge voulait entendre tout le monde là
le juge a entendu tout le monde et le
juge dit et bien maintenant peut
remettre en liberté sous conditions il a
versé une caution il peut pas aller à
naner il peut pas porter une arme bien
entendu pas rencontrer les témoins et la
famille il a fait 4 mois de détention
provisoire franchement moi je trouve que
c'est pas scandaleux mais je trouve
normal qu'il a fait 4 mois qu'il sortte
maintenant c'est bien normal qu'il ait
fait 4 mois de détention provisoire la
table oui ou non ou ou non non de toute
façon le moi enfin pardon hein mais on
n' pas le droit de critiquer la justice
on n pas le droit de bah enfin il est
communément admis que
criuse ENF le fait est que on comprend
rien pardon mais on comprend rien les
affaires les unes après les autres moi
je comprends pas quelle est l'échelle de
sanction et là en l'occurrence pour je
je pense que cette décision a été prise
parce que c'était on était dans un
climat extrêmement compliqué et que
c'était une décision tout simplement
politique un juge il est aussi sensible
à ce que peut lui dire sa hiérarchie il
est aussi sensible à un environnement et
il a pas forcément envie de B
sa hiérarchie en prenant une décision
qui va à l'encontre de ce que attendent
les politiques pour vous ah non j'ai
trouvé ça scandaleux qui son en prison
je trouve on peut pas dans une société
mettre sur un pied d'égalité une
personne qui a décidé de rentrer en
délinquence et de faire des braquages de
faire des vols et cetera et quelqu'un
qui se lève le matin en ayant décidé de
donner sa vie à la protection des autres
à la sécurité des autres et qui trébuche
un moment dans sa vie certes c'est c'est
un drame mais qu'on tribuche on est
c'est pas la même façon qu'on est
policier qu'on déboue sa vie à la
sécurité quelqu'un qui qui est
délinquant c'est pas la même chose 4
mois pour vous il dev non il va allit
faire quoi il allait s'enfuir il allit
faire comme ça c'est quelqu'un qui qui
qui est entraîné à respecter la loi qui
est foncière autrement il aurait pas
fait ce métier là il aurait fait
délinquant on peut choisir un moment
dans sa vie on fait policier on fait
délinquant c'est pas le même chemin donc
pour vous c'était normal ah bah c'est
scandaleux et d'autant plus si on le
restitue à côté de l'affaire dont on a
discuté il y a quelques minutes comment
est-ce que quelqu'un qui traîne qui
refuse d'obtempérer un jeune qui refuse
d'obtempérer qui a volé un véhicule qui
refuse d'obtempérer qui traîne un
policier sur plusieurs mètres qui lu
fait un traumatisme crâen il peut être
libre le soir même libre le soir même
c'està dire non seulement il a été jugé
à rien mais il fait pas de préventive
par contre un policier multidécoré aux
états de service irréprochable qui ne
représente absolument aucune menace pour
la société en dans l'attente de son
procès comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'embastiller pendant 4 4 mois et demi
c'est c'est c'est absolument honteux et
si on doit juger les si on doit juger
les policiers mais que diantre pourquoi
ne juge-t-on pas aussi les juges juges
les juges qui sont responsables de ce
lac judiciaire qui qui libère à tour de
bras vous voulez que j'ai plein
d'affaires là ENF j'en ai quelquesunes
attende non mais juste à Argenteuil
Samir B suspecté d'agression sexuelle
sur deux nunagénère garde à vue remis en
liberté le 16 octobre 2023 un homme de
29 ans a été mis en examen et placé sous
contrôle judiciaire pour des menaces de
mort antisémite à l'encontre de Cyr et
d'Arthur qu'est-ce que vous en pensez il
a été remis a été remis en liberté le
soir même un homme de 22 ans qui avait
qui avait été tué par balle fin octobre
à Brest l'un des suspects éta mis en
examen pour meurtre par le juge
d'instruction et l'autre a été placé
sous statut de témoin assisté personne
n'a fait de préventive alors c'est des
cas gravissimes pourquoi est-ce qu'il y
a une justice attendez pour non mais
j'ai les références on va pas faire on
pas détailler ici mais pourquoi les
pourquoi attendez je termine par ça
pourquoi la police quand pourquoi quand
on est policier on est on a on a
pas
me mais attendez mais pourquoi vous
pourquoi
vous pourquoi vous éthnicisé comme ça
enfin c'est c'est incroyable c'est quoi
ces réflexes là je dire parce qu'il
s'appelle Samir c'est pas grave et quand
il s'appelle
christop
mais ce sont vos confrères qui les
nom mais la question que je pose c'est
pourquoi quand on est policier on est
soumis à une justice d'exception c'est
ça la question quand on est policier et
bien la justice vous tombe dessus à bras
raccourci au nom probablement d'une
idéologie parce qu'on sait très bien que
la magistrature est gangrainée par une
idéologie d'extrême gauche le Syndicat
de la magistrature pour ne pas le nommer
représente 35 % des juges il était à la
manif représenté à la manifestation
contre les violences policières ce qui é
déjà une honte et donc effectivement la
police les policiers les forces de
l'ordre de manière générale sont jugé
pas de la même façon que les malfras
parce que vous comprenez un certain
nombre de justes sont là pour juger la
société et pas pour juger les coupables
ils en face deux vous euh Jean mé vous
êtes là aussi ragir pour les 4 mois de
prison moi ou pas pour les 4 mois de
prison est-ce que vous trouvez normal
qu'il est plus 4 mois moi moi je pense
que c'est normal qu'il a pris 4 mois en
fait je pense que c'est normal parce que
voilà vous me prouvez le contraire tu as
vu le RO trip de Na ou pas non mais
attends mais moi je suis toujours pour
la sévérité ici vous allez pas me dire
que moi je suis pas pour la sévérité à
chaque fois je dis quand il y a un
policier qui est en danger si'il doit le
policier qui a tiré en l'air j'ai trouvé
ça super bien je suis toujours pour la
sévérité je suis toujours pour le
respect des des institutions et on ne
joue pas avec la police sauf que le
profil qu' a dit ù je me trompe c'est
qu'il était connu lui de ces policiers
là le petit Naël il le connaissait on
m'a dit qu'il le connaissait les
policiers il savait où il habitait on
savait que cétait un gars
particulre il le connaissait et je
trouve que c'est un peu démesuré de le
mettre en jou et il démarre et on enlève
la vie bon c'est un gamin qui fait des
conneries mais on enlève une vie il
faudrait que le
policier tu as vu le de ou pas parce que
donc il a les vidéos surveillance on a
vu son périp donc il roule il manque de
percuter une dame avec 7 il manque de
percuter un cycliste là il est bloqué
parce qu'il y a des et là on lui
demande de couper de couper le moteur il
ne le fait pas comment on fait en fait
comment on fait s'il repart et si je
sais pas il percute quelqu'un il y a la
mort de quelqu'un
comment si tu le FLI il y a aucun
problème s'
F me on arrêtebat Paron do par s'en fout
personne ne tweet personne dit mon petit
rien à des flics mais dans dans
ce cadre là comment veux-tu que le flic
fasse contre
concrètement mais ça dure 2 secondes ça
du 2 secondes comment tu veux com
l'avait pas arrêté qu'ils avaient
renversé ton gamin qu' l'avait tué tu
aurais dit quoi moi si y a mon gamin on
pass
gamin content mais je suis le premier
pas content tu rigoles ou quoi tu aurais
mis tu aurais mis en cause tu aurais mis
en cause la police en disant elle a pas
fait son boulot elle aurait dû l'arrêter
moment fa choisir que il roule dans une
voiture qui est immatriculée en Pologne
il n'a pas de permis il a 17 ans elle
n'est pas assurée non mais ça fait de
jours qu'il fait le KK en tu vois il a
pardon tu peux arrêter quelqu'un sans
facile à dire sur les plateau
té
tu crois que vraiment ce policier seè le
matin en disant ou allez je vais tuer là
c'est bien c'est un super métier il font
des métiers c'est des humains il
font tu dis la cévérité doit être la
même pour un policier ou pour un
délinquant moi je crois pas du tout ah
non je dire pardon mais la société ne
peut pas punir de la même façon un
policier quelqu'un qui est là pour te
protéger pour faire en sorte que cette
personneel qui a une arme dans la main
éventuellement ne blesse pas quelqu'un
d'autre après je veux dire c'est de ça
dont il s'agit c'est terrible la
question excusez-moi mais là
pr le débat le débat est quand même
assez incroyable parce que excusez-moi
les policiers sont là pour faire
appliquer la loi aucune personne au
monde lorsqu'elle obéit aux policiers
quand les policiers demandent de vous
arrêter ne risquent quoi que ce soit à
partir du moment à partir du moment où
vous décidez d'en freindre la loi en
nérant pas à des gens qui sont
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
c'est ça l'État de droit on se gargarise
de l'État de droit uniquement
bizarrement quand il s'agit de pas
expulser des gens en dehors des
frontières mais l'état de droit il
commence là et si vous si vous
obtempérez pas ben vous mettez le doigt
dans un engrenage qui peut vous conduire
à des drames mais c'est la faute de qui
à la fin à la faute de celui qui n'a pas
obtempéré n'a pas été respecté pour ce
policier qui a demandé donc des des du
parloir systématiquement et le parloir
lui a été refusé depuis juin voilà donc
c'est quand même incroyable justement
pour vous donc sa place n'était pas en
prison vous avez des nouvelles de sa
famille je suis en contact avec sa
famille j'ai eu son épouse tout à
l'heure vous a dit quoi bah qui m'a dit
qu'elle était soulagée c'est ça euh de
voir son son mari libérer ils ont dû
déménager d'ailleurs c'est une famille
qui a été c'est une famille qui qui est
allée qui qui est entrée dans la
tourmente dès le 27 juin puisque leur
adresse a été dénoncée sur les réseaux
sociaux ils ont été obligés de déménager
dans un contexte où où le traitement
c'est le salaire du policier et je parle
sous le contrôle de monsieur bellad a
été interrompu donc ils ont eu des frais
de déménagement le l'adresse de leur
hôtel a été à nouveau dénoncé ils ont
été obligés de déménager dans un autre
hôtel ils ont un enfant en basâge et
bizarrement la société a trouvé ça
incroyable en tout cas une partie de des
médias et des politiques a trouvé ça
incroyable qu'on fasse preuve de
compassion vis-à-vis de la famille de ce
policier donc on était obligé d'avoir de
la compassion pour la famille d'un petit
voyou ça çaavait pas de problème mais
par contre pour la famille d'un policier
alors ça il fallait pas il fallait pas
en avoir s' vous plaît vous avez cré une
cagnotte Jean Mia oui pour le policier
pourquoi vous êtes mêlé de cette affaire
vous parce que j'ai trouvé ça incroyable
que effectivement on
crée on mette la famille d'un policier
dans une situation pareille j'ai estimer
que l'État en tout cas l'administration
qui au nom de laquelle il il est
intervenu dans la rue ne le protégeit
pas assez ne protégeit pas assez sa
famille et je suis comme des millions de
Français j'été scandalisé par le
traitement de ce policier combien sur la
cagnotte 1632 € ah ou quand même pour
87000 donateurs qui qui a touché
l'argent sa femme ça y est c'est bon ou
ah ouais maintenant est
passéa Sousa veut dire qu'il faut
tuerel je apporter une petite précision
une petite précision faut savoir qu'
aussi l'amical des motards du 92 a
ouvert une quête qui elle na enfin n'a
que nous on l'a fait pour la famille
parce que malheureusement on a plusieurs
cas où les les femmes et les enfants se
retrouvent seuls on a récolté enfin
l'Amicale des motards du des haut scèes
a récolté 85000 € qui eux sont la
famille pe les til d'accord mais l'autre
le million il est sous ses CAES non il
il est pas enfin il est pas sous ses
caisses c'està dire que comme il y a une
procédure la famille préfère pour
l'instant ne pas y toucher mais ils
l'ont ils l'ont touché ils l'ont touché
euh vous êtes convoqué par la police
pourquoi alors euh quand j'ai ouvert
cette cagnotte évidemment la gauche et
l'extrême gauche les parlementaires et
cetera vous vous avez des débats
homériques à l'Assemblée nationale se
sont offusqués de cette cagnotte et donc
ont saisit euh d'abord le procureur et
la la famille de Naël a porté plainte
contre moi tenez-vous bien pour
escroquerie en bande organisée donc moi
évidemment moi le motif je suis tombé
des nuus je me dis le parquet pas touché
un € au vous de la cagnotte ben moi en
fait quand on ouvre une cagnotte ceux
qui ouvrent des cagnottes le savent on
est obligé de donner la pièce d'identité
du bénéficiaire et le relevé d'identité
bancaire du bénéficiaire qui en
l'occurrence c'était pas moi donc
l'argent n'a pas transité par mois ni
par aucun tiers l'argent de la cagnote a
été versé directement sur le compte du
bénéficiaire c'est-à-dire l'épouse du
policier ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que qu'elle n'a pas
été ma surprise que le parquet sur des
motifs aussi fallacieux a décidé en 24
he d'ouvrir une enquête donc moi je me
suis dit bon bah si c'est ça je vais
porter plainte moi contre la cagnotte
ouverte pour la pour la famille de naë
pour les mêmes motifs dans une forme de
sétrie risquez quoi jusqu'à aujourd'hui
le parquet ne m'a toujours pas répondu
donc après quand on veut me vendre
l'idée d'une justice indépendante et
impartiale excusez-moi j'en ai eu ma
coupe risquez quoi bah pour l'instant
rien parce que je convoqué auditeur en
audition libre donc d'accord donc ça va
voilà donc si vous voulez parce que le
problème il est quoi escroqueré en bande
organisé j'ai escroqué qui quel bénéfice
j'en ai tiré personnellement moi
financier rien si j'ai escroqué les
87000 donateurs de la cagnote c'est à
eux de porter plainte pour escoquer
bizarrement personne l'a fait donc à
moins qu'il considèent que les 87000
personnes c'est la bande organisée
auquel cas les donateurs vont porter
plainte pour diffamationan M ce qu'il a
fait c'est qu'il a pris des informations
confidentielles du traitement des
c'est faux c'est pas prouvé ça arrêtez
défamé c'est faux c'est ce pourquoi vous
allez être entendu on est d'accord ce
qu'on lu qu'on vous repravoir fait je
peux même pasention ce que vous dit ce
qu'on ce qu'on vous reproche d'avoir
fait ce que la famille de Nel vous
reproche d'avoir fait c'est d'avoir pris
des informations avoir divulgué ces
informations confidentielles Cyril pour
criminaliser Naël et donc les donateurs
ont donné en croyant que Naël était un
criminel
multirécidiviste pourquoi ils ont pas
porté plainte ils ont donné pour une
raison fallacieuse c'est qu'on lu
reproché plinte pardon il y en a aucun
qui a porté plainte non mais c'est la
famille et l'avocat de la famille donc a
déposé une plainte qui a été jugée
recevable et il y a une enquête autour
de ça
voà vous avez présenté na s un jour qui
n pas selon la famille c'est cousu de
fil blanc pas du tout j'ai pris les
informations qui étaient disponibles à
l'instanté d'ailleurs je ne suis pas
convoqué pour ces motif vousêtes
convoqué pour quoi alors je suis
convoqué uniquement sur le chef
d'accusation des m organisé parce que le
reste ne tient pas la rout c'est ça
lesescoc organisé je viens de vous la
définir c'est incroyable ça vous faites
le boss sur une affaire et maintenant
vous présentez comme la victime imp
possible vous dites que j'ai trompé les
donateurs est-ce que un c'est la justice
d'accord la la justice est-ce que un
seul donateur a porté plainte je parle
de la justice je parle pas des donateurs
c'est pas ça quel est l'intérêt de la
famille à agir pour le compte de
donateurs est-ce que les donateurs ont
donné procuration à la famille de Naël
pour porter plainte contre moi pour
escroquerie pour et deè
question si si ouvrir une cagnot si
ouvrir une cagnotte si ouvrir une
cagnotte vous vaut d'être accusé
d'escroquerer en bande organisée moi
j'ai porté plainte contre la famille de
Naël pour escroquerer en bande organisé
pourquoi le parquet ne m'a toujours pas
répondu parce que votre plainte elle est
bidon alors que elle est recevableelle
est pas recevable elle est recevable
politiquement voilà la vérité c'est pour
calmer les zones de non France après les
émeutes voilà c'est tout vérité ser
entendu lundi je serai entendu lundi ou
raconter si vous voulez bien pour moi
c'est une convocation
par et même l'acceptation de la plainte
par le parquet à l'époque on était
encore dans les émeutes le parquet
probablement sous l'inluence sous
l'influence de journaliste gauche
progressiste dont vous êtes d'accord il
a décidé
effectiv d'envoyer un signal aux zones
de non France pour les calmer parce que
c'est politique c'est
tout vous nous direz lundi d'cord je
vous
Lund tout
suite